I'm just throwing this right here at the
very beginning of the video I made a
mistake there the reaction and trailer
number two it looked like that that was
a Thor's muni hammer but then I realized
that it was just the angle that threw me
off but no that must have been store
breaker so always Stormbreaker guys I
hear the comments even though I haven't
read any of those that said that but I
hear the chopping either reject nation
I'm Greg I'm John if you watched our
reaction for this special look know that
we've been up since about 455 am there
really got about two hours of sleep I
kept waking up like wide awake any
slight noise because I was so anxious
about trying to grab the end game
tickets is said to be on sale by 5 a.m.
everyone say a little bit 4 or 5 insane
theaters lashing since yeah I know that
we've seen some concert people were able
to get their tickets I don't know what
state you're in I know a couple people
in California who texted me saying they
managed to grab some tickets I don't
know man we got me on it you on it we
got Andrew on it it overall just keep
getting logged out and we've been at it
for it it's 643 right now as we're
shooting this no side is loading might
as well try to do a breakdown of this
video because there's lots of gather
from it that I really did quite enjoy I
feel a little bit more awake than when
we did the reactions oh look you have
let's hop into this now shall we the
first thing I want to point out is that
moment with cap in the mirror really
stands out to me because that must be
when he shaves his frickin beer he's
gonna use every one of those mirrors
yeah his face is flawless okay and you
can see the razor right there razor
doesn't it you know it's not what you're
expecting as part of the breakdown maybe
I don't know when he shaves that beard
when these images are so restricted you
got to dive deep a lot of the trailers
have you know been touching on different
themes you know like obviously start off
with feeling very desolate
you know that once then the other second
trailer really honed in on the struggle
battle like element in terms of the
internal you know I got some external
elements but it's but we're mounting the
final offensive it's it's very kind of
we're setting out on the journey whereas
this one even though you get some of
that desolate vibes and you get
hope elements makes it pretty clear you
know I have a hard time believing it's
just a trailer manipulation that shot
that we've seen the other trailer is
where the characters are looking up at
the sky like who's returning yeah
just based off the environment it must
be right atonia nebula with Tony and
nebula return
you know Tony reuniting with pepper
you've got in two trailers now where
he's just really trying to reunite with
her now we see here that he reunites
with her which is awesome yeah confused
that they decided to show that in this
chair actually just because you know
it's been such a huge lead of those
other ones is him talking to the mask
you know leaving the message taking it
back actually well and then you have
this other moment which I think could be
a very powerful emotional moment where
you have nebula and Rockets saying next
to each other because you know Rockets
part of the guardians of the galaxy the
whole team vanished away on Titan where
nebula was there to witness it but
rocket wasn't you know he was off with
Thor I imagine in that moment that
nebula has to a also give the
confirmation of what happened they're
probably gonna have like a bonding
moment in terms of the loss they
experienced together yeah one they're
both two characters that have been like
built and cobbled together so I gotta
imagine that they have kind of a unique
place to bond from yeah and all this
because in the next shot you see they're
holding hands as well you know because
nebulas always kind of been at or like
weird odds even with the guardians you
know oh yeah so in this moment this is
when they were uniting together but even
like with this series of images that are
going over with Tony's you know having
that line about it's not about how much
we lost is about how much we have left
yeah that's what I mean that those
little elements of hope and even get
that mode with row number as tats are
being shown off just been going through
like a rock and roll fitness but he even
gives like a little nod and it's the
first time he looks remotely positive in
any of these trailers you know ready to
go and get some revenge yeah and then
Tony step I feel like the Tony and
nebula effort there'll be a lot of just
very sad vibes from the team and I
imagine
when Tony and nebula returned that's
when you get this moment of being
instilled with some hope I think more
than just for the audience before the
characters yeah I mean if you're if
they're able to at least reunite with
the remaining team I gotta imagine
that's gonna be a huge catalyst for the
entire hope engine of this movie sure
sure
you know with even Tony's saying you
know to cap you trust me
I do yeah that handshake which is really
cool you know after the events of civil
war we have yet to see them reunite the
environment made it look like it was
part of Avengers 1 you know like because
we saw those set photos where they
towers like pretty apparent they
time-travel back and then even with the
shot with Iron Men in the sky that looks
like it's out of the first Avengers
movie I mean that could be an idiot hit
point in time honestly because in New
York and Iron Man's going over the city
on the suit looks a lot more modern
there's something about that shot that
just feels like it's from the first
movie I don't know if that's intentional
ro I'm just reading into some random
shot here
a City escape during the daytime with
Iron Man the reason a question - is that
moment with cap and Tony of saying you
trust me part of the time travel element
what I first watch it that's what I
immediately thought but looking at it he
you know you see him wearing two
different suits in this trailer and from
what I can best gather that suit in that
moment is from the winner is the Winter
Soldier outfit but then you see that
other shot which looks like it's in that
same moment from that badass moment in
trailer - were you shields is the
struggle face that outfit I believe is
the Captain America Civil War outfit and
the reason why it looks like that is
because there's got the a patch on the
side I'm not sure you know why he's
changing so many awful again the
America's gotta get every costume back
the best way to dye it back to the first
one you know do I want to go back to
like my biggest appearance and as cool
as that shot is - with the whole group
standing standing together I do notice
that you know in this shot you're still
missing a couple of players here you
know Thor you don't have to worry you
don't have Captain Marvel in this show
yeah I don't know if they're off doing
something different maybe they're just
across the room from everybody
understanding across the room for when
they had this door mouth or that was
pretty cool it's got to be a different
moment than that obviously were just
making a joke but it's got to be
different on that because black widows
in that shot and and then also she has a
blonde hair in that shot whereas in this
group shot she has her red hair going
and also this shot of like when they're
kind of going into hyperspace yeah I per
Drive that's the garnish the galaxy
Benatar ship it's like the inside was
like the community ship but it's the
seatbelts
Yesi about some like yeah that's that's
star-lord seatbelt like the way the
design isn't everything so Captain
Marvel is using that based off the other
trailers too safe to assume that the
ship that Tony and nebula used to get
back is the benitar so that would make
sense why they're using it but in the in
the Benatar I don't know if they're just
maybe taking a couple of ships because
you know you don't have net like you're
those Bennett sorry you don't have
nebula here you don't have iron man here
you don't have ant-man as well a lot of
the times of the timeframe elements it's
like okay wait a minute there's black
water here with blond hair caps and his
Winter Soldier outfit so what point of
time is this exactly you know what I
mean yeah so it seems like cap Marvel is
probably gonna unite with them it's also
based off the you know spoilers it's
made almost a billion dollars at this
point and it's the end game trailers
it's based off the post credit scene it
seems like will first happened is
Captain Marvel will unite with them
they'll go on a mission and later Tony
whatever events happen from this mission
Tony and nebula will return yeah after
or whatever this mission is and maybe
rocket and Thor because we see that in
the other chose or in an isolated
environment but it looks like they're at
that same location so maybe that's why
that group shot they weren't together
the narration to a fast is lying if you
couldn't live with their own failure and
and there's to a couple images that
really stand out to me they're obviously
Tony looking at Peter out of all the
loss that's the main one he feels the
most for but then you also have nebula
and war machine looking at each like war
machine given her and you know that's
like weird nasty he's really turned on
yeah you know
like end-of-the-world scenarios really
revving engine sister because she's got
she got a sharp focus look and he's like
yeah you know word we're getting revenge
for our friends but you really into this
yeah that moment with Thanos showing up
you know there's a couple of things what
it looks like he's kind of coming
through the Bifrost yeah yeah it looks
like he's materializing somehow or maybe
he just wanted to make a big entrance
yeah who does you know like the he
appears in that famous moment in
infinity war we desert that hole yeah
the smoke and stuff he's using the
gauntlet there to go through that here
looks like maybe the gauntlet is damaged
or broken because it seems here that
he's traveling through the Bifrost in
this moment at least that's the way that
that's how the Bifrost looks when you
travel through it he's also fully
armored up and then we saw those toys
where he had the double bladed sword
yeah so I do imagine that perhaps just
maybe this you know like maybe the
gauntlet is actually broken or a motor a
couple or maybe one of the stones
doesn't work or something something has
to go there must be something wrong with
the gauntlet to the point where he's not
just using it if he's all fully armored
up that means he's getting ready the
battle yeah I feel like we saw that in
either Infinity Ward's teaser image or
something with the goblet looks real
busted up well yeah yeah it's an
infinity war after he uses it after the
snap so I mean he's able to use it to go
to get away though so mate but maybe
over it maybe it was just temporarily
went along in the last remaining battery
life Victoria yeah maybe even meet all
the stones to do it or something yeah
but I am curious as to what's going on
with that you know because he
practically fights them in a tank top
and the other one you know whereas here
he's like I need to Gartley to wear some
gear make sure I'm ready - yeah - the
Scarecrow down and put it back on I
didn't make sure Stormbreaker doesn't
make sure he doesn't take my advice this
time at this point does he need to put
on a bunch of gear does he does he need
to do that if the gauntlets working he
could just snap them away
yeah he's preparing for battle and you
love that lied to you cannot live their
own
word of that bring you back me of course
of course it did you're still alive but
we're also they gonna go yeah they're
not gonna get revenge on somebody else
yeah I'm not gonna reverse somebody
else's master plan I guess the last
thing is is you see that cool shot with
the Trinity of Ironman cap and Thor
walking towards Thanos who in the
blurred background looks like he doesn't
have his helmet on and is perhaps a
little exhausted yeah a little tired my
question is from this trailers that you
don't see Hulk at all that any of these
yeah
and I'm kind of wondering if this is the
mid-battle moment or something could
this possibly could Hulk possibly be
there oh if they could just as easily
edited Hulk into infinity war trailers
that could just as easily edited out
exactly maybe he smashed Thanos and now
our heroes they're about to step up yeah
that's the game there must be yeah I
don't imagine this is the final battle
that we're looking at this is probably a
midpoint battle or something yeah we've
got to imagine that this is much of a
big deal as they've made about like oh
we're only showing you know clips from
certain parts of the movie even if
they're not telling us the full truth
about that I don't think it goes to the
finale a battle for food exactly I can
see first prep primarily the trailers
our first 15 minutes but there's just no
way although there's no way I'm like
this is the most rush movie ever
this is great stuff I'm excited we have
press greeting tickets so now we just
gotta get our regular because I want to
go on IMAX and be with an opening crowd
you know you know goes anyway guys any
fun theories you gather from this
trailer comment below you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and check us on
patreon we do weekly q and A's TV show
reaction stream along some with pilot
reaction highlights included and John
does music video covers